[Música]
Hola comenzamos el espacio dedicado a
medio ambiente aquí en France 24 yo soy
María Clara calle el tratado ambiental
más importante después del acuerdo de
París comenzó a discutirse Y es que el
28 de noviembre empezó En punta del este
Uruguay la primera de seis reuniones del
llamado comité intergubernamental de
negociación su objetivo es llegar a un
acuerdo internacional que sea legalmente
vinculante para poner fin a la
contaminación por plásticos el comité
fue creado en marzo de 2022 cuando la
asamblea de la ONU para medio ambiente
que se reunió en nairobi tomó 14
decisiones para hacer más alcanzables
los objetivos de desarrollo sostenible y
una de ellas fue precisamente crear el
comité cuyo objetivo es alcanzar el
acuerdo internacional la importancia de
que esto se logre es que se cambiarían
las acciones fragmentadas que se han
hecho hasta el momento y que en gran
medida han dependido de voluntades y que
generalmente no implican obligaciones
legales
como consecuencia de esto la
contaminación por plásticos en el mundo
ha aumentado drásticamente al punto que
la asamblea de la ONU de medio ambiente
dijo que era una epidemia y el
pronóstico es que empeorará según el
reporte de la ocde sobre perspectivas
mundiales del plástico a 2060 el consumo
de este producto en todo el mundo se
disparará al pasar de 460 millones de
toneladas en 2019 a casi el triple en
2060 con más de 1200 millones de
toneladas
esto hará que los océanos estén más
contaminados por plástico pues se pasará
de 30 millones de toneladas de este
producto en 2019 en los océanos a 145
millones en 2060 una situación similar
ocurrirá también en ríos y lagos que al
2019 tenían 109 millones de toneladas y
en 2060 se estima que tengan 348
millones
es por todo esto que la ciudadanía pide
que sí se logre un tratado la
organización
wwwf y Plastic free foundation revelaron
una encuesta realizada en 34 países en
la que muestran que ocho de cada 10
personas piden que los productores de
plástico sean responsables de estos
productos que generan y que también se
prohíban los plásticos que son difíciles
de reciclar además siete de cada 10
personas apoyan que exista un tratado
que cree reglas globales vinculantes que
es precisamente lo que se discute en
Uruguay Pero cuál es la diferencia entre
un tratado global y los acuerdos
fragmentados y voluntarios que existen
hasta ahora para entenderlo
conversábamos con María Alejandra
González quien fue a punta del este para
acompañar las negociaciones como asesora
de política regional para plásticos de
WWF Esto fue lo que nos dijo
a pesar de que en los últimos años gran
parte de los países del Mundo han
aumentado las políticas que van
dirigidas a detener la contaminación por
plásticos principalmente medidas por
ejemplo de prohibición de plásticos y un
solo uso la contaminación por plásticos
continúa creciendo significativamente y
en los últimos cinco años en más del 50
por ciento la contaminación por plástico
es un problema ambiental transfronterizo
pero que también tiene impactos no
solamente ambientales sino también
sociales y económicos Y esta es la razón
por la cual todos los países decidieron
en la última reunión de la asamblea
Ambiental de Naciones Unidas tener un
tratado global sobre contaminación por
plásticos y establecer Esas reglas
internacionales que permitan que
efectivamente se detenga la
contaminación por plásticos pero por más
que se esperen reglas internacionales
las negociaciones no son fáciles Pues
hay diferencias estructurales entre los
países y los intereses que defienden en
la como lo explicó María Alejandra bueno
gran parte de las dificultades se
encuentran uno en los diferentes
contextos nacionales que tienen los
países hay países que son productores y
exportadores netos de productos
plásticos Pero hay países por ejemplo
que tienen menos control sobre los
productos plásticos que ingresan a sus
mercados porque son importadores netos y
no tienen producción otra de las
dificultades que quizás ahora en la
negociación o diferencias tienen la
negociación es que los países en
desarrollo necesitarán mayor apoyo no
solamente un apoyo financiero pero
también un apoyo de transferencia
tecnológica y de conocimiento para poder
hacer frente a las medidas que se que se
van a adoptar y estos otra de las
discusiones que se tendrán no solamente
Cuáles son las medidas globales a lo
largo de toda la cadena de valor del
plástico sino también Cuáles son los
recursos que necesitarán sobre todo los
países en desarrollo y las pequeñas
Islas para poder hacer frente a las
medidas que se tomen en este acuerdo
y la intención es que todas estas
discusiones de las que habla María
Alejandra terminen en 2024 cuando el
comité de intergubernamental debería
Mostrar el primer tratado mundial que
regule la contaminación por plástico
Pero puede ser una fecha difícil de
lograr Esto es lo que nos explicó la
experta en relación con otros tratados
que han abordado problemáticas
ambientales es bastante ambicioso hablar
de tener un texto negociado y adoptado
para finales de 2024 Sin embargo es
posible está el compromiso de los
gobiernos está el apoyo de la sociedad
civil y también toda la información de
la ciencia Que hoy ya evidencia y tiene
bastante información para tomar
decisiones concretas para para detener
la contaminación por plástico ya veremos
qué pasa en Uruguay y en las reuniones
que vienen así llegamos al final de La
Crónica Vean este y todos los episodios
de medio ambiente en francés 24.com
[Música]